I
[Music]
it's
the two versions okay so the first one
goes
down then inter project two independent
for down then
project the one I wanted you to do is
the last one
down into the pro
one
down and combining
first one down and
then second one combine
for
[Music]
first version all the way
down then
in second version still down but
combined
when you pay attention the his feet are
in the technique but his energy is
allowed to pass under it okay so as I
go I still kind of go down and the third
one we did I'm just kind of in the
middle don't take it all the way down
but have the sense of where his feet is
that his feet are in the lock feet are
in the lock
okay so that means
that I could probably have his feet in
the lock up
here
okay doesn't have to do with going
down have Fe
in can't go up and
cut let feet are in the
technique but I'm not going down that
was a
cut in the
Techni
down there we go play with it play with
different heights
go what's key though is like I'm not on
the outside here you see that like a
knife Ed here and then I I
push you need you need your hand to
still over the
top okay
like you I'm in his feet here I I can
feel his feet here when you add his
energy that's coming forward then the
head's going to go backward you see but
you can't be here and do that yeah I'm
not just pushing him away so he has to
still over you see I'm over the top okay
and then you unloaded the back foot his
energy keeps coming forward and boom now
projecting over the
top sometimes uh and so I might go you
feel like you're locked here right oh
your mind's just a little off just yield
a little more now you're over to top you
see but if I don't feel his feet
especially like can stop moving forward
then you can go lower you see do
likewise if you turned on me here you'll
have this one over
here he turns on
me find back your Center turn on you
find your
[Music]
CER this like in the Nea the next
opening opens up don't contest it come
around and no one would ever know I was
trying for the other techniqu did I try
for the other Techni
[Music]
hey